[Laughter]
thousands of migrants are stranded on
the border between the european union
and belarus which president alexander
lukashenko opened his country for anyone
who wants to take a risk and get into
europe so he effectively opened a
gateway for anyone who is willing to
risk a trip to belarus and then try to
jump across the border into poland or
lathania through forests swamps and
fences of barbed wire
belarus is ruled by alexander lukashenko
the president who has been in power for
27 years last year he claimed the
victory in presidential elections which
triggered an unprecedented wave of
protests at one point it even seemed
like his rule was about to end but then
he was able to suppress the opposition
with more than 30 000 arrests
the west promised to step up its
sanctions to which lukashenko replied
that in that case his country would no
longer have neither the money nor the
desire to stop illegal immigrants from
poor and into the european union
russia which supports lukashenko with
cheap energy and money said the west
should talk directly to him to resolve
the crisis
lithuanian poland object saying he only
needs this to get back his loss
legitimacy and make the west abandon
sanctions against his regime
and yet the outgoing german chancellor
angela america called lucashank on
tuesday after which he pulled back some
migrants away from the border of poland
sheltering about a thousand of them in a
nearby warehouse
migrants many of them young men made
several attempts to break through the
border into poland but it became
increasingly clear that it's just not
going to happen
as of today thousands of them are stuck
between poland and belarus unable to get
into the european union and apparently
not able to go back because belarusian
authorities are not allowing them to
leave the area
it remains unclear what's going to
happen next